when you cut a deck of cards in half the
number of red cards in one of the piles
will be the same as the number of black
cards in the other pile every single
time it's math there are 26 black cards
and 26 red cards in a 52 card deck now
dividing such a deck in half gives you
two piles of 26 cards each red and black
cards will be mixed in each pile but
consider the number of black cards in
one of the piles add to it the number of
red cards in that pile and you get the
total number of cards in the pile 26 but
now take the number of black cards in
that pile and add to it the number of
black cards in this pile well that will
just give you the total number of black
cards which is 26. both of those numbers
are the same distance from 26 which
means they are equal the number of red
cards in this pile is the same as the
number of black cards in this pile